[Music]
I'm so excited to be sitting here with
one of my favorite people one of the
funniest people I know from your
wonderful YouTube sensation hit its
grace internet famous super hilarious
and wonderful oh thanks for Gavin grace
helbig I put a dress on for a photo
shoot the other day and I felt like it
wasn't right
dresses are weird there's never away I
feel like it's like someone wrapped a
towel around themselves getting out of
the shower I'll just go out in this this
is it I don't need anything else why
it's a bizarre thing to have the wind Oh
coming right up into your cooter yeah
it's the legs the coop to the coots goop
what a racket
weave like some pervy guy was like I
call it the dress pants and cut out the
seams here's the part that protects the
part you want to protect the most I take
it out of called the dress it's $75 and
this is the old time and that's a lot
about it I like this it looks like there
was a storm in Hawaii a cocktail party
it's all right when I was a kid I was
obsessed with those little umbrellas oh
yeah me too I used to think like you
know it could cover me a little bit I'll
okay like I kind of thought that wasn't
my skewed perception of what a cool boy
would be like I'd be in junior high and
I'd be like no it's raining but pretty
light and everyone would be like
[Laughter]
very progressive thinking from middle
school I didn't get my first [ __ ]
till I was 21 okay and you know what I
thought as soon as she started what
we're gonna get married and you know
what we did you got married yeah BJ
today wife tomorrow you opened a tiny
umbrella over her head what's your
favorite thing to do on a casual girls
night in like this um drink drinks and
eat snacks what kind of snacks bugles
put them on your fingers fun super fun
I love guacamole me too guacamole is my
favorite flavor do you make a tableside
I hate when guacamoles made tableside
because you have to hear it we have to
hear it and then you just have to kind
of like just a second you can put this
in your mouth
if you like I can look up these bananas
do so much for coming
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
did you go to camp look at this
personality I went to camp
fan song industry no but you were
enjoying it oh yeah your camp song that
you had when you were younger
can we do a camp song yeah ready unity
fun that's safe in the side yeah make a
bracelet with your platonic boyfriend go
in your cabin you weird girl who don't
like camp your skin is so pale your
nicknames the scam camp and fun for
everyone
cept that one weird girl food's real fun
too tater tots oh the name of you
[Laughter]
as a hug sound a hug sounds great
do you want a hug and then do the
guacamole sound I'll let you take that
one we're hugging nope no I didn't know
what's happening during the hug I
thought it was hug and then the noise
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]